>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC
>> We have Marilyn Nelson.
She was born in Cleveland and was
raised on several Military bases.
Her books include The Fields of
Praise, New and Selected Poems,
which was a finalist for the 1998
Lenore Marshall poetry prize,
the 1997 National Book Award
and the PEN/Winship Award.
Magnificat and the Home Place,
which won the 1992 Anisfield-Wolf
Award and was a finalist
for the 1991 National Book Award.
Momma's Promises
and For the Body.
She has also published two
collections of verse for children.
Including The cat walked Through
the Casserole and other poems
for children with Pamela Escalante.
Her honors include
two push cart prizes,
two creative writing fellowships
from the National Endowment
for the Arts, a full
bright teaching fellowship
and the 1990 Connecticut Arts Award.
Since 1978 she's taught at the
University of Connecticut stores
where she is a professor of English.
Her latest book is Snook Alone,
which is illustrated
by Timothy Basil Ering.
And guess who we have here?
Timothy Basil Ering.
He's illustrated numerous
books for children of all ages
and he's the illustrator and author
of the popular picture books,
Next Out for Adventure and the
story of Frog Belly Rap Bone.
What a great name wow, which
has been adapted for the stage.
Ering is also the illustrator
of the Newbery award winning
The Tale of Despereaux...
[ Applause ]
>> ...y Kate DiCamillio.
It's been published
in many languages
and was made into a motion picture.
I remember that.
He also recently illustrated Finn
Throws a Fit by David Elliot
and he's the illustrator of
Marilyn Nelsons Snook Alone.
He's the contributing illustrator
of the serialized story called
The Exquisite Corpse Adventure,
available exclusively on The
Library of Congress website.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
Okay were on now.
Thank you very much.
That was a -- Marilyn
and I had talked
about giving a slight introduction
about ourselves and who we are
but that was fantastic so I
think we're going to move right
in to talking about Snook
Alone, this new book
and we just did a book signing
just about a half hour ago.
We had a lot of people in line with
this book so it's really exciting
to see this new, new book
out and in the public.
So were just going to kind of going
to share back and forth and talk
about inspirations and I'm wondering
if maybe would you like to speak
because the writing came first
and I know you have some friends
and your travel and islands
and emotions that all went
into this book and
maybe people would
like to hear about
your inspirations.
>> Marilyn Nelson: Okay
this book began for me,
it grew out of my friendship with a
man who is a former Benedictine monk
and is now a Roman Catholic Priest
on an island in the Indian Ocean.
We were friends from
college forty-five years ago.
I was visiting once several years
ago and he had three little dogs,
little I think they were Jack Russel
Terriers although I made Snook a Rat
Terrier because I wasn't sure.
He had these three little
dogs who were adorable
and one of them was named Snook.
It was both of our favorite and
while I was there I happened
to read a magazine article about
someone who had abandoned a dog
on a uninhabited island
and he and I talked
about what an awful thing
this was to do and I said,
"You know I think the
adventures of a dog
on an island though could be
a nice story for children".
>> Timothy Basil Ering: I by the
way didn't know the whole time
illustrating this until
towards the end
that there really was this character
Oba Jacob she calls Oba Yacum
[phonetic] and a real dog Snook so
later on when I met with Marilyn
and talked about this
stuff I was like excited
to see an actual photograph
of Oba Jacob.
It was probably best that I didn't
see that in the beginning either
because then I would of tried to
make it look like him maybe so
but keep going that was...
>> Marilyn Nelson: So we
spent some time talking
about what could possibly make
the, we figured it would be him
in the story and his dog and what
would possibly make him leave his
dog behind on an uninhabited island.
Just by chance one of the
things my friend is dedicated
to is the preservation of a
atoll in the Indian Ocean,
St. Brendan's atoll and he had the
previous year made an excursion
with some other people to
do a survey of the animals
and birds living on these tiny
little islands in this atoll.
So we put that into
the book and the book.
Maybe you should talk a little
bit about because it's a sea book.
It's a book about islands and I will
say one last thing before handing it
off to Tim again.
My friend who he had gone on
several silent solitary retreats
on these islands in this atoll and
so he said well he gave me a map
of the atoll so that I could see
all of the islands in the atoll
and then he said well it probably
would be best to put Snook
on this one particular island
and then he drew a map
for me of this island.
This is where he would probably
be able to find fresh water.
This is where the seabirds
are nesting.
This is the vegetation in
this part of the island.
So I left my visit with
him with a map of the atoll
and a hand drawn map of
AdvoCare Island and the image
of Snook himself who was
a very, very sweet dog.
He was the one of the three dogs,
Snook was the one who would sneak
into my room in the guest house
at night and sleep at the foot
of my bed even though
he wasn't suppose to.
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
On a green mat?
>> Marilyn Nelson: Yeah
well actually in a chair
which he really wasn't
suppose to yes.
So although I myself have not
been to this island I was equipped
with a strong sense of the island
from my friend and with a sense
of the adventures that
a dog would have
on an uninhabited island
in the Indian Ocean.
>> Timothy Basil Ering: Alright
so as an illustrator a lot
of times you don't met the
author right off the bat.
I guess as I get farther into
my career maybe I'll work
with a author a second time or
something and will have already met
that author but a lot of times you
get this manuscript it's just a
typed out xeroxed black and white
just like you get in school,
these little assignment and I read
that you know Snook Alone
is this beautifully written.
I don't know if anybody's read
it yet but heres, this is it
and it is beautifully written.
>> Marilyn Nelson: It
just came out last week.
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
The fourteenth I think
was the release date.
So I was excited immediately
because I'm going to tell you
about how I was inspired
to illustrate this.
I had, I just brought a couple
little snapshots, I just printed
out these little just some
old pictures I scanned in.
So first of all I grew
up with having dogs
and this you probably
can't see it that well
but this little dog here his name
is Caesar and he was a awesome,
awesome dog I mean everybody
could say that about their own dog
but he just had such a personality
and he used to go out on the boat
with us all the time fishing
and if we had to many people
in the boat he had to stay on
shore we could watch him barking
and running up and down that shore
as we got farther and father away
and we would literally go
back and say, "Okay get in".
So his personality of just hanging
out with him whatever you know
of we were just taking
walks in the woods
or down the beach I
had all those memories
of you know the dog
personality stuff to kind of plug
in to this Snook who I've
never met that I felt
like I knew already just
by reading about him.
So there was kind of
like the dog inspiration.
Then I had a lot of
excitement in my body and mind
about where this was taking
place and this whole island thing
and there's a couple reasons.
I love, I'm a beach bum,
I grew up on Cape Cod
and I just spent a lot
of time at the beach.
I still do.
I love surfing, fishing, boating all
that kind of stuff, and adventure
and so this whole island thing
was like oh this is great I get
to draw this cool stuff,
this island stuff.
I'm holding up a picture of the
United States ship Kitty Hawk
and I was stationed on this ship,
I was in the Navy before
I started art school,
I went to The Art Center
Collage of Design in Pasadena
but I wasn't quite ready for school
yet even though I loved drawing
and everything I was just like
I wanted to run my friskies off
or whatever it was so I moved
from Cape Cod went all the way
to California, I'm on this ship
and we sailed all over the place.
I went to Hawaii and Africa and
Japan, the Philippines and Australia
and Diego Garcia and it was
an unbelievable adventure
and like heres a old picture
of me, just a silhouette,
I was on Diego Garcia and
walking around the tidal pools,
just like this is all relating
to the book stuff, catching stuff
like little octopus
and spiney lobsters
and all kinds of cool stuff.
So after college I, this all
relates to [inaudible] illustrate
in the book, my Dad had been
trying to learn how to sail
for years growing up on the Cap,
breaking his knuckles and knees
and just trying to learn how wind
goes through sails and eventually
when all us kids, there was five
of us, got out of school he saved
up his pennies and bought
a boat that was worthy
of sailing farther
than just Cape Cod Bay.
He says, "Would you
like to go on a trip?"
I said, "Are you kidding?
I would love to".
And he wanted to sail
from Florida to Guatemala
and for five months I was on a
boat with my Dad and we sailed
on a little thirty foot boat
from Florida to Guatemala
and it was a trip of a life time
and on that trip we just had
so many adventures I
can't even tell you.
We saw you know beautiful scenes
like going through we went
on the Bahamas all over the place.
Little light houses and that
light house for the first example
of how illustration
you're inspired by memories
as an illustrator is just a little
tiny drawing here in the beginning
of the book and it doesn't
necessarily have to look exactly
like what I saw as a light house
but I just picture that little read
and white stripped light house
and I plugged it in right there
and you just start putting in your
own memories as well as these images
that you're developing
from reading text.
So there's stuff like that and
then there's stuff like this these,
she talks about living
a little hermitage.
I saw I actually for eight bucks a
night folks these little grass huts
and I actually did one of
my first books The Diary
of Victor Frankenstein
it was back in 1997.
I was drawing it while I was
sailing on this trip and when it was
to rough out there, the seas
were to big we would pull
into these little places and
for eight dollars get one
of these little huts and I would
sit in there and draw for a day
or two till the storm
kind of settled down
and that leads into storms.
I saw all kinds of
storms again relating
to that's how Snook is separated
from Oba Jacob by a huge storm
and Oba Jacob has to
take the boat and go
to the leeward side of an island.
So I was thinking about
all my travels during this
and these little anchorages that's
our boat right there in the middle
of the uninhabited island
in the middle of the ocean.
It was so awesome.
So all this is relating to
the story and I was thinking
about you know trudging around
the mangroves were snorkeling
and in fact one time he was
just talking about adventures.
I know what the cards going to
say ten minutes left [inaudible]
and I know I got side tracked but
we were snorkeling in this lagoon
and it's a great idea when you
anchor to hop out of the boat
and dive down and check on your
anchors visually with your mask
to make sure they're set
because these squalls
and these storms come
through all the time.
So we get down there and make sure
that [inaudible] anchor is
wedged right in that sand
and then we say okay lets
just check out the area see
if there's any good
lobstering around here.
My Dad and I were swimming around
this, I mean there's no one around
and were in there for about
30-45 minutes and were coming
up to this other shore, this
little coral reef and like
where you're walking down the
streets sometimes you just feel
like you get this weird sense where
you just kind of want to turn around
and feel like there's somebody
there it's just human nature sudden
instincts and I had
that, I turned around
and there was this huge
bull shark right there.
He just like his from his throat
to the top of his head was
like that deep the pecks
were open just like you see
on Discovery Channel and we weren't
snorkeling we were just I mean we
weren't scuba diving we were
snorkeling and so we had
to keep coming to the
surface and he's right there
and my Dad he kept tugging
on my fins here and there
like he's joking about
the shark thing.
I poked him in the ribs
told him to go up looked
at him one time took my
snorkel and said big shark.
We put our heads down there
it was going broadside right
in front of us.
I had caught a barracuda and
to keep it fresh I hung it
over the side of the sail boat.
I forgot all about it, it
was dumb, it was a bad move.
We were so excited to get in the
water so we started swimming back
to the boat because we said if we
stay on shore were going to be there
for weeks trying to make
a raft out of coconuts,
there's no help here we
better get this done now.
So we swam very calmly back to the
boat in the middle and I could see
that crystal clear water.
I could see the barracuda
hanging down
and another shark under the boat.
We get up onto the boat, I slopped
up onto the dingy the little
zodiac we had, Dad tried to climb
up the little latter on the
back of the transom with his,
I joke about it all the time,
he's got his flippers on they're
that long, the latter's got about
that much room between the latter
and the transom, he
crawled up on his knees
with his flippers peeled back
like little onions and we looked
in the water, ripped our masks off
and there were three bull sharks
that circled our boat for
like forty-five minutes
and I'm recalling all this because
Snook was looking for little fish
and stuff in these little
tidal pools in this island
and Marilyn describes like being
aware of these little baby sharks
that are prowling around, these
little predators and stuff.
So I literally had deep thoughts
for like to be inside Snook's mind
as well as like having my dog
memories and all that kind of stuff.
You know heres like a little spiney
lobster we caught so she describes
like creatures and stuff in there
so these all related and I was
so excited so as an illustrator the
way I like to work is from memory.
All day long I look at stuff I
stare at things I'm defiantly one
of those guys that gets,
stops to smell the roses,
I stop and smell the
roses I start to look
under the rose bush every bodies
already ten minutes ahead um there's
a turtle and I'm at the rose bush
for like a half hour and late again.
So I like to take those memories and
try to draw without looking at scrap
of course I had to look up here
what does a rat terrier look like
and I loved that he had floppy ears,
I love floppy ears
rather than pointy ears.
So I started drawing and I was
on this trip, I was in Kansas
and the first drawing
that came out of Oba Jacob
and I don't think I've shown
you this yet it was on a napkin.
I'm going to have big slides,
I do school presentations
and I'll have this on PowerPoint,
these will be big and colorful
but for now I just because of the
time we didn't have PowerPoint
but write on the napkin then I
bought a bagel I was in the airport
and I opened up the
bagel bag and laid it out
and just started doing my
first sketches on the back
of the bagel bag of Oba Jacob
and I love this little kind
of round shape, this little round
head and the monk kind of shape
and so I brought those back
to the studio and got started
on the sketches and that's the whole
way it all started happening for me
and I recalled this trip you know
the adventures that I've been
on while illustrating this thing
and there's an image
of you know the storm.
I don't know if I can find
everything here right away but.
Here's when they go on the adventure
and they get this assignment
to catalog the plant and animal life
on the surrounding atoll islands
and that's just what my dog used to
do you know go right up to the bow
and his ears would be flapping
in the wind just like you said
and I could it was just like
illustrating is hard I mean
when you have a blank white piece
of paper its hard sometimes an hour
or two goes by and nothing good
happens you know you got your it
takes a long time to
finally start making
so I lie this first scribbling
but with Marilyn's writing things,
I had that image in my head
and I know about the storms
and holding a boat into the waves.
You know if you have the transom
of that boat with the waves coming
like this the waves smash against
that flat part of the transom
and water gushes up into the boat
and you can swamp and
sink your boat.
So just like I was enjoying
that I could draw these little
you know heres a couple of guys
that were helping out and they're
holding this boat with the bow
into the wind and you know
I love all this stuff.
You know Snook was busy
snorting around for rats
and so there he is just howling into
the wind and it's just helpless.
He is officially separated
from his buddy.
So and then mornings I love like
going surfing early in the morning,
first light fishing, walking
down a big open beach,
I don't know if you've ever
been to Cape Cod miles and miles
of beautiful beach that are just
untouched and there's no cottages
or anything just beautiful dunes
and all those memories you know come
through when I'm doing that and
just almost everything in there is
from things I've experienced and
even though being on Diego Garcia
to see these like coconut crabs,
these giant crabs and stuff.
So for you guys that are looking
for a little adventure and a lot
of emotion this story
is really cool and Snook
when he is alone he really does
have all these cool things happen
and like there's the shark
one where he's like looking
around his little tidal
pools and stuff like that.
I wonder how much, where are
we at for time right now?
Where's our timer?
We have 15 minutes left?
Okay so we were going to
save some time for questions
and answers would you guys
like to ask the questions?
>> Marilyn Nelson: I would
like to say one thing first.
I just want to say that although
every book has several levels
of meaning and although this
book is an adventure story
about a dog that's left
on an island it's kind
of a dog version of Robinson Crusoe.
On one level that's all it
is, is an adventure story
but as I said it began for me with
a friendship with a former monk
who has himself sailed, he sailed
once from Southern Africa to Brazil
on a sailboat with four other people
and he's a man whose had adventures
but for me the book
began with the idea
that it could teach
young people something
about what it means to pray.
The Snook belongs to a monk
and so he has spent his whole
life following the rhythms
of the monk's life, which is
a rhythm of work and prayer.
So that when Snook is left alone
on the island he conducts
his work as usual.
His work is to catch rats that's
what he does, he's a rat terrier
but the work is punctuated by
periods when he sits on the beach
and listens to the waves when
the waves become like the sound
of his breath and he sits there
longing for his friend, his Oba
and I had hoped that
this would be a book
which would enable grownups reading
it to children to talk a little bit
about what it means to long
for someone who loves you
and who you know is out
there but you cant see them.
>> Timothy Basil Ering: This
is the good stuff folks.
>> Marilyn Nelson: I'm
hoping that there are
that it's a story with
a couple of layers.
It's not necessary to read that
second layer into the story
because it's a terrific adventure
but it's possible to use this story
as a way of thinking
about something else
in our universal human experience.
So I don't know whether I have a
minute to read a little tiny bit.
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
Oh yeah, yes, yes.
[ Applause ]
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
This is awesome.
>> Marilyn Nelson: This is
the beginning of the time,
the book begins by describing
the life of Snook with his Oba,
what they do every day and then it
describes how they get separated
and this is the beginning
of Snook's aloneness.
In the morning there were only
faint sips of his friends scent left
for Snook to drink
in here and there.
He sat on the beach watching a band
of clear sky filled
with streaming light.
Snook was thirsty he sniffed
past the squealing rats and mice
and the nesting birds, quack,
quack as they rose in alarm
and formed a black spiral overhead.
He followed his nose to a
sandy hollow in a circle
of velvet leafed Argusia bushes.
There he dug attentively
at first then as the scent
of fresh water grew stronger he
dug furiously making the sand fly.
At last he lapped sweet water
then he made his well larger
and drank and drank.
On his way back down to the
beach he marked many trees.
[ Laughter ]
>> Marilyn Nelson: Okay that's
enough now we can have question
and answer.
[ Applause ]
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
Can I ask a request?
>> Marilyn Nelson: Yes.
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
Can you read just one more?
We can't give the ending away.
The ending is just like fabulous.
>> Marilyn Nelson:
I read from the book
on the day it was published
I read the first part of it
and then I thought well
that's enough I had read
about five pages a man said no
how does it end, how does it end.
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
This is a good one.
>> Marilyn Nelson: I read one more
page then this is a description
of the sea turtles come
ashore to lay their eggs.
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
There are sharks too!
[ Laughter ]
>> Marilyn Nelson:
Maybe should I read now.
By afternoon the northwest
beach had been scored by dozens
of carapaces the high dry
sand dug up and covered
by many graceless flippers.
But one last turtle
was still digging.
Snook lay in the scant shade of
a Ceriana and watched her labor.
Her beak opened as
if to pant she dug
with one rear flipper
and one healed stump.
Her eyes half closed streamed tears.
She seemed as old as the world.
She laid dozens of eggs,
covered them with sand
and as dark fell dragged
her weight back to the deep.
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
Is that like good or what?
That is such much good writing.
[ Applause ]
>> Timothy Basil Ering: And
then Snook's alone again
like even his little
sea turtle friend
that he had for a coupe of minutes.
>> Marilyn Nelson: It's something
I read about sea turtles is
that when they come ashore
nobody can explain why they weep.
They weep tears and
so the weeping eyes
of the sea turtle become
something inside of Snook
in his heart it fills him
with compassion again this is
the second layer of meaning.
On one layer it's just a sea turtle.
[ Laughter ]
>> Timothy Basil Ering: Those
words make illustrating so fun
when you get to have
an assignment like that
to work with words like that.
Thank you Marilyn for
that that's awesome.
>> Marilyn Nelson: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Timothy Basil Ering: Unless you
have something else you defiantly
want to add.
>> Marilyn Nelson: No I
don't, I hopefully have left
at least a couple of
minutes for a couple
of questions, if there
are questions.
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
Oh wait we have a...
>> So much and I was
wondering don't you have a book
about George Washington
Carver, is that who he is?
That is one of my absolutely
favorite books so its not a question
but I just wanted to tell you
how much I appreciate that book
and I use that with my
students who are going
to be teachers all the
time and we all love it.
Thank you.
>> Marilyn Nelson: Great, thank
you, thank you, thank you.
I think about Carver a lot lately
because among his inventions were
gasoline made out of peanuts,
motor oil made out of peanuts and
there was something just recently
that was, oh someone is
starting to make some kind
of a peanut based food for
famine, something about some place
in like Kenya where
people, there's a famine
and somebodies made
this peanut based,
Carver did that sixty years ago.
Exactly the same thing, but
her never, he's not connected
to his discoveries because he
didn't sell the formula he gave them
away free.
So I read all the time about things
that new people are making money on
but they're really Carver inventions
that were made in the forties.
So thanks for mentioning that book.
>> I wondered if you had any pets.
>> Marilyn Nelson:
I grew up with dogs.
I had lots of dogs in my lifetime.
My, I'm not sure, I had
two who were wonderful.
One was an Irish setter and one
was a miniature pincher miniature
Doberman but my Irish
setter was a genius dog
and she was scarily
intelligent, really so yeah, you?
>> We have two kitties and
they're pretty smart to.
They learned how to open
up their food box so.
>> Marilyn Nelson: Yeah you don't
want a pet that's quite that smart.
Yeah I had a friend who
had a dog that learned how
to open the refrigerator.
[ Laughter ]
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
I had a goat and a rat.
A pet goat we used to
go clamming with it.
Everybody's like that not a
dog they're with that's a goat.
>> I guess you have to put
a lock on the refrigerator.
I'm curious you mention that
you start out with drawing
but then later on when you go
to the finished illustrations
what medium do you use?
>> Timothy Basil Ering: I use
acrylic a lot because I do like to,
I use actually all kinds of mediums,
oil and acrylics and charcoals
and inks and everything but
I do use acrylics a lot.
One reason I like them is
you can create layers quicker
with the acrylics because I
use heat guns and water bottles
to spray them, like kind of a road
paint, and then a rusty erosion
with heat kind of like a hair dryer.
And then you can quickly add
layers on to that and it's still
in that same session not waiting
for oil layers to dry and stuff so.
Acrylics mostly I'd say.
>> Hi the text comes first right
and the pictures come afterwards
so you don't change the text
I assume it stays what it is
but did you guys ever
argue about the pictures?
>> Timothy Basil Ering: I don't
think we've ever argued ever.
[ Laughter ]
>> Marilyn Nelson: There
was one very small thing
because as we've both said Oba
the Oba is a real person and so
when the first sketches came
to me I sent them to my friend
and my friend is a
monk but he's vain.
[ Laughter ]
>> Marilyn Nelson: He said well you
know the Oba's a little bit rotund
we changed one of the
sketches here we thinned him
out a little bit yeah, yeah.
But it wasn't an argument.
>> Pixar says story is king
and that's totally true however my
little it's not even a question,
the statement is the pictures
that you created drew me
to this book before I even knew
who was going to be speaking.
I didn't know you were the
artist for Tale of Despereaux.
Despereaux wouldn't be
despereaux without your art.
[ Applause ]
>> Timothy Basil Ering: Oh
my goodness that is so much.
Thank you so much I have to
say when you're making art
when you're writing just making art
in all the forms you're
almost you're an introvert.
I'm able to speak for myself but
like I do hear similar things.
You're in the studio by yourself
and you're trying to create
and you have this blank white
page or paper or computer screen
or something and you're there
for a lot of hours alone trying
to figure this stuff out and
you know my eyes get glassy
when I hear stuff like
that because you have this
like huge extrovert life
of when this book comes
out you do stuff like this.
Like the National Book Festival this
is so awesome and to hear comments
like that I will defiantly be in a
taxi like headed to the airport just
like wow you know and
then call my Mom again
like its just awesome
thank you for saying that.
[ Applause ]
>> Two quick questions.
One is Timothy in the
picture of the lighthouse is
that Hopetown in Abaco
in the Bahamas?
>> Timothy Basil Ering: No that
was I think that was NASA light
because we checked in there because
of a big storm we were headed
to the Berry Islands at
that time and I think.
Have you been to NASA.
>> There's two yeah ones in
Hopetown Elbow Key in the Bahamas.
The second question is how
did you originally come
to your collaboration, how
did you two get together?
Did you know your work,
was it your publishers,
agents, how did it happen?
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
Well from what I'm finding
that the publisher puts authors
and illustrators together
and because we hadn't
met before the book
and Marilyn sends the manuscript in
and Candlewick press is who we work
with they just have an arsenal
of illustrators and writers
and they kind of know
everybody's style
and they approached me they read
it first and said Tim might have,
because you know I
developed a friendship
with my editor Karen [inaudible]
is the president over at Candlewick
and they more you know about each
other kind of the better it is
because she knows my love of
adventures and sailing and water
and all kinds of stuff so that's
how you're placed a lot of times
without even meeting
sometimes till the end.
>> Thank you both very much.
>> Marilyn Nelson: Thank
you all for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Timothy Basil Ering: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov Page 1